c'est une rentrée particulière pour les
élèves du collège magellan à chanteloup
les vignes dès leur arrivée désinfection
des mains et port du masque obligatoire
38 élèves de 6e font leur retour dans
cet établissement d'une capacité totale
de 2 199 élèves distance d'un mètre
séparation des tables à la cantine
affiche tout le protocole sanitaire a
été mise en place
le ménage est également accentuée dans
ce collège qui accueillait les enfants
du personnel soignant pendant le
confinement
on ne fonctionne plus comme avant les
enfants n'ont plus de carnet de liaison
ça veut dire qu'il ya plus de punitions
il ya plus d'heures de retenue donc je
vous dis c'est une vraie un vrai rapport
de confiance d'accueil on essaie aussi
de s'adapter davantage aux élèves dans
les classes
onze élèves maximum sauf dans les salles
de sciences avec 15 élèves certains
professeurs continuent le suivi des
élèves à distance mais la plupart des
enseignants sont de retour il met en
place des projets pédagogiques avec
leurs élèves
la fresque qu'ils veulent perdre dans la
cour ou qu'il s'agisse pour vivre va
raconter cette histoire de déconfinement
de faire une chanson avec une artiste
elle les enfants pensent aussi aux
vacances dans ce contexte particulier la
ville proposera des activités
c'est un principe il n'y a pas une
journée on ne propose pas quelque chose
à un groupe de groupe trois groupes
utiliser l'ensemble du territoire et
tout ce qu'il a comme équipement public
comme équipements d'extérieur
troisièmement travailler sur toutes les
tranches d'âge faire de l'éducatif du
culturali du sportif tout mélanger et
faire autant que peu se peut et sait ce
que j'étais en train de valider du
de la mise à distance aussi certain
nombre de possibilités à l'extérieur 41
% des élèves ont déclaré revenir au
collège magellan à partir de lundi